eu sou a fontes
apesar do meu sotaque é eu sou
nordestina
nasci numa cidade que se chama igreja
nova em alagoas e como minha colega
falou ontem se tiver alguém aqui é
porque certamente aparente alguma coisa
assim
a minha família eu sou uma de dez filhos
os meus pais migraram pra ir pra são
paulo em 1970 é por algum motivo meu pai
veio na frente com os meus dois irmãos
maiores e até hoje eu não entendo porque
minha mãe veio depois com os seis filhos
menores ela sozinha não dá pra entender
até hoje porque isso e numa viagem de
dois dias e meio de alagoas até até
diadema onde eu passei a minha infância
inteira
bom como todos os nordestinos a nossa
vida foi extremamente difícil né a gente
trabalhou muito batalhou muito a vida
foi sempre muito dura é nada foi
entregue fácil nem de bandeja pra gente
mas o meu pai e minha mãe apesar de na
época serem semianalfabetos eles
pensavam muito na questão de educação
eles não falavam com educação eles
falavam ser preciso estudar se estudasse
preciso estudar o tempo inteiro eles
falavam isso até porque eles não tiveram
essa oportunidade de estudar é dos oito
filhos que vieram para são paulo se deve
estar pensando se ela falou 10 e agora
são oito né e infelizmente dois
faleceram no nordeste mesmo por questões
de de seca falta de condições morreram
de doenças muito simples
dos oito filhos cinco conseguiram
terminar a universidade conseguiram é
seguir essa carreira de educação e
trabalhar
eu fiz duas faculdades com extrema
dificuldade
lembro que quando eu passei na primeira
universidade é na época tinha uma coisa
de você acha que já tem até hoje você
pagar a matrícula da escola eu tinha o
dinheiro para a mensalidade mas eu não
tinha para matrícula então uma das duas
coisas tinham que resolver uma vizinha
super bondosa porque existe gente
bondosa no mundo isso é absolutamente
maravilhoso
uma vizinha da minha
na época resolveu pagar a matrícula e eu
acabei entrando na universidade ela
pagou a matrícula
eu paguei a mensalidade só que eu
ganhava não dava para pagar a
mensalidade então todo mês há uma
dificuldade se imagina 20 anos atrás
vinte e poucos anos atrás é todo mês eu
devia uma mensalidade e fazia bolo pra
fazer bolo fazer a torta para vender na
faculdade morria de vergonha de vender
então eu pedi para os meus colegas
venderem porque isso pra mim era bem
difícil e aí tinha uma coisa que que
hoje a gente acha completamente absurdo
na época não tinha código de defesa do
consumidor
então quando você devia universidade a
mensalidade eles colocavam seu nome no
quadro na universidade pra todo mundo
ver a linda né você chegar e ver
devedores do mês né a nomes todo meu
inclusive quando vi aquela primeira vez
eu fiquei super envergonhada chocada eu
falei gente q horror e vergonha todos
vão ver que estou devendo e aí quando
você fazia prova do mês você quem estava
devendo tinha que pegar a prova na
tesouraria para poder fazer passar por
todo aquele processo sabe só prova não
está aqui vai lá na tesouraria e aí a
primeira vez que isso aconteceu eu falei
gente que vergonha como é que eu vou
fazer pra pegar minha professora todo
mundo vai saber que não devendo né tá no
quadro todo mundo vai ver mas aí quando
eu levantei para pegar minha própria
tesouraria 30 alunos levantaram juntos
também foi raul não sou só eu todo mundo
também deve que legal e aí todo mundo
comigo todo mundo que de viajo beleza
feito fantástico
enfim é fiz a minha primeira
universidade terminei fiquei devendo um
ano depois que terminei foi uma loucura
mas paguei depois na época não tinha
nenhum programa de governo para ajudar
ninguém se tinha que ir lá e falar mesmo
não tinha nenhum apoio da universidade
eu tinha sonhos meus pais também têm
exceções de trabalhar numa grande
corporação eu trabalhei em várias
corporações e boa parte da minha vida
numa única grande corporação
tive várias frustrações durante esse
processo construir uma carreira mas hoje
eu consigo enxergar olhando da minha
visão de hoje lá trás consigo enxergar
várias frustrações que eu passei como
até um certo bullying é preconceito uma
série de coisas mas eu não enxergava
isso naquela época
é construir essa carreira várias vezes
eu tentei ser promovida e várias vezes
que eu tentei ser promovida o que eu
denomino hoje de kit perfeito não tinha
eu não tinha boa formação porque eu não
tinha estudado em colégio particular eu
tinha estado em colégio público minha
vida inteira é eu não falava inglês e eu
não vinha de boa família
eu ouvi isso em algum alguns processos
seletivos internos ign desculpa você não
tem você não estudou em colégio
particular você não estudou no
universitário de primeira linha e é
claro que o bolsa família não falava nem
gente espera eu que depois intérprete
que era por causa disso também mas enfim
é eu continuei eu sou super batalhadora
fui atrás construir essa minha carreira
e algumas coisas começaram a me
incomodar durante todo esse processo
vou contar um exemplo pra vocês de
várias coisas que eu passei durante esse
mundo corporativo essa vida inteira que
eu tive é de uma vez a participar de um
processo seletivo e no processo seletivo
o diretor que estava querendo me
promover lá olhou para o meu currículo e
falou assim nossas o currículo é
fantástico é igual a vaga e olhou na
minha cara falou pena que você mulher e
eu assim eu não fizesse a porque eu fui
eu me senti culpada
eu falei assim mas porque eu não posso
forçar porque não porque veja bem eu
quero alguém que seja um forte que seja
briguento que seja a macho e que brigue
com os funcionários e você tem uma cara
de muito boazinha
eu falei ah tá bom ok aceitei continuei
continuei minha carreira mas aquilo foi
plantando uma sementinha durante todo
esse processo eu não entendia isso como
discriminação eu não entendia isso como
sendo o bullying ou coisa parecida eu
entendi assim que eu estava errada e por
que eu era mulher e não conseguia
assumir aquele cargo e colocava um monte
de culpa em cima de mim
enfim passei quase 17 anos nesta
corporação é agradeço muitas coisas não
sou grata a deus muitas coisas que eu
conquistei por lá mas aí em 2007 e já
tinha minha primeira filha e aí aquilo
me incomodava muito porque eu tinha que
trabalhar muito como todo mundo que
trabalha em uma grande corporação não me
incomodava trabalhar muito
o que me incomodava era aquela de
a mica além do dia a dia de sacrifício
sem ter um mínimo de flexibilidade para
cuidar pra vocês terem uma idéia da
minha primeira filha é eu sair de
licença o parto da minha filha foi no
domingo eu parei de trabalhar na sexta
feira à noite no domingo a minha filha
nasceu e dois meses depois estava de
volta ao trabalho o que é absolutamente
absurdo pra quem é mulher sabe que esse
momento esses 44 5 meses que você tem
que conviver com a sua com a sua filha
com a sua família ou enfim aquele
momento mágico de vocês e mãe eu
infelizmente não vive esse momento da
minha primeira filha
bom enfim 2007 eu estava super chateada
não tava num me sentia mais feliz de
estar naquele ambiente e resolvi pedir
demissão dessa empresa
e aí quando eu pedi demissão a reação de
todo um país para onde você vai que a
empresa você vai trabalhar eu falei não
eu vou pedir demissão vou ficar em casa
durante um período eu quero dar uma
fazenda de talks né ficar em casa um
pouquinho para ver se as coisas ficavam
um pouco diferentes
e aí eles falaram 'você vai tirar um
sabático falei 'não gente vou ficar em
casa nessa batida em casa entendeu em
casa o olhar as coisas tudo fiquei nove
meses em casa cuidando da minha filha me
virei dona de casa verde o motorista da
família cuida de todo mundo e todos do
cartório banco porque quando a gente
trabalha em casa as pessoas não acham
que a gente trabalha né
está em casa fazendo alguma coisa enfim
foi um período muito importante pra mim
muito interessante me fez bem né viver
aquele momento mãe tá tá na minha na
minha na minha casa cuidando de coisas
que eram mais do dia a dia
em 2008 eu resolvi abrir o meu 1º
negócio é quando ninguém falava de de
empreendedorismo aqui no brasil antes de
abrir seu primeiro negócio fazer um
parente seu trabalhei numa outra
corporação durante oito meses mas eu
falei isso não é pra mim mesmo de jeito
nenhum
quero construir outras coisas quer achar
meu propósito quero buscar uma outra
vida e aí é saindo dessa outra
corporação eu resolvi empreender no meio
desse processo chegou minha segunda
filha porque ela chegou mesmo chegou um
presente de deus é a gente estava no
processo de adoção na fila e depois de
dois anos e meio ela chegou foi uma
é uma alegria muito grande você deve
imaginar como isso deve ser não posso
ficar falando muito senão vou me
emocionar
enfim e aí em 2008 abriu seu primeiro
negócio virar empreendedora quando no
brasil em prender ninguém sabia o que
era pra onde era e como fazia cometi
todos os erros possíveis e imagináveis
como empreendedora todos eu tenho uma
lista
posso fazer uma palestra de umas três
horas sobre todos os erros que eu cometi
e aí eu encontrei finalmente o meu
propósito de vida porque eu vi que nos
meus erros
eu encontrei várias outras mulheres que
também estavam empreendendo e
empreendendo pelos mesmos motivos que eu
estava empreendendo que era encontrar
alguma coisa que eu gosto de fazer que
tinha o propósito e que ao mesmo tempo
eu conseguisse ser uma pessoa normal e
consegui olhar para as minhas filhas
conseguir de vez em quando levar as
minhas filhas na escola é passar os dias
jantar com elas enfim ter uma
convivência maior é hoje eu sou
empreendedora eu tenho três negócios
desde então mas a minha causa de vida é
ajudar outros empreendedores e
especialmente ajudar mulheres
empreendedoras é isso que eu faço é isso
que o que eu mais amo e porque eu amo
ajudar mulheres empreendedoras é
primeiro porque é meu propósito que eu
sou empreendedora eu passei uma série de
dificuldades e isso é muitas pessoas me
abraçaram muitas pessoas me acolheram
estiveram junto comigo para me ajudar
e hoje eu consigo é fazer isso por quase
200 mil mulheres no brasil inteiro que é
o trabalho que a gente tem na rede
mulher empreendedora e porque eu ajudo
essas mulheres empreendedoras a porque é
bonito porque é seu propósito porque
você gosta de ajudar as pessoas
também por isso mas eu ajudo mulheres
empreendedoras porque essas mulheres
quando elas têm micro e pequenos
negócios quando elas são reconhecidas e
quando elas têm a empresa delas dando
certo sabe onde elas investem acham que
elas investem roupa pra elas
vocês acham que elas investem em comprar
coisas para elas
elas investem nos filhos elas investem
na família desculpa me emocionar
elas investem na família e elas investem
sociedade mulheres quando elas têm um
negócio que dão certo elas investem na
comunidade onde elas estão
elas ajudam as pessoas elas ajudam os
funcionários
elas ajudam a comunidade delas a ser uma
comunidade melhor ea conseguir fazer com
que as pessoas andem com ela também de
forma melhor
mulheres ajudam a família estendida
delas elas conseguem ajudar o pai a mãe
o irmão e todo mundo para que consiga
junto com ela e consiga trilhar o
caminho do sucesso junto com ela e por
conta disso porque essas mulheres têm
essa representatividade porque nós somos
52% da população mundial
e detalhe né nós somos mãe da outra
metade então vamos combinar que a gente
tem o dom que a gente tem o poder e
vamos combinar
e aí sempre sempre me perguntam é uma
pergunta muito frequente
você acha que as mulheres podem dominar
o mundo vocês acham que as mulheres
podem dominar o mundo
também eu também acho mas eu acredito
mais ainda do que as mulheres podem
dominar o mundo que as mulheres podem
melhorar o mundo eu acredito nisso
fortemente quero que vocês acreditem
nisso
junto comigo também muito obrigada